i'm brent office good to have you with
us we begin with breaking news and a
green light for nato expansion after six
weeks of debate native secretary general
jen stoltenberg says that turkey has
agreed to support the bids of finland
and sweden to become members of the
military alliance ending a major debate
over the issue
the three countries have signed a joint
memorandum
to quote extend their full support
against threats to each other's security
now this is a reversal by turkish
president erdogan who had opposed
swedish and finished membership claiming
that the countries provide shelter
to a kurdish group that ankara regards
as terrorists the successful resolution
of the row over the nordic countries
membership is a big boost to nato as it
seeks to bolster its defenses in the
face
of russia's war in ukraine
here's nato secretary general
stoltenberg announcing the breakthrough
just a few moments ago
in nato we have always shown that
whatever our differences
we can always sit down
find common ground and just solve any
issues
nato's open door policy has been an
historic success
welcoming finland and sweden into the
alliance
will make them safer nato stronger and
the euro-atlantic area more secure all
right let's go now to our correspondent
jack park he is at that nato summit in
madrid forest jack they have been
talking about this now for weeks worried
that turkey was going to stand in the
way that has changed how did this
reversal come to be
well they've been in talks before the
nato summits has started brent this has
been an extensive set of talks this
afternoon into this evening and we've
just had now this announcement that
turkey is removing its block now what
does it involve this memorandum that
we're talking about we haven't actually
got it in paper form yet but from the
press conference that yen stoltenberg
gave i'll just run you through exactly
what he's said he said that the two
major agreements between turkey finland
and sweden are firstly on arms control
we don't exactly know the details of
that yet but the second is on terrorism
and trying to work together to counter
terrorism and we know
that they have agreed that they will and
this is what they say is to commit to
tackle threats to nationals to the
national security of turkey and to crack
down on pkk terrorists with an agreement
on extradition this is an interesting
detail because turkey accuses finland
and sweden of harbouring members or
connected people to the pkk terrorist
organization the terrorist separatist
group
and the big question is what will this
agreement now mean will those people
that have find safe harbor in finland
and sweden who claim to be uh you know
fighting uh for their freedoms against
turkey in that in the conflict between
those those two uh you know parks people
two areas uh will they now face
extradition
jen schottenberg said that this will uh
all be done under european human rights
law but he also said that tomorrow when
the leaders meet in earnest all 30 nato
leaders but they will invite sweden and
finland to join the nato military alone
yes yeah i mean the details there it
sounds like the details have to be
finalized on that but we do have a green
light and so what is this going to mean
jack then for
the the summit this nato summit that
you're attending in terms of support for
ukraine
it's a really interesting one i think
brent because i think we were all
expecting that this two-day summit was
going to be a real grind over this issue
u.s president joe biden who's already
arrived here in madrid he was meant to
be meeting
tomorrow directly one-on-one with russia
tayyip erdogan the turkish president to
try and hammer out this issue but now it
looks like it's resolved all of the
foreign ministers of the three countries
have nice sat down and resolved this
which means as you say that they can
focus on ukraine we already know that
nato is going to put 300 000 troops on
high alert on the eastern flank of the
military alliance over the concerns of
what russia is doing and now really they
can also get to grips with tackling how
they're going to support ukraine which
all of the nato military alliance wants
to do specifically with weapons we've
had the klitschko brothers here in the
press room earlier saying that they need
weapons in ukraine in order to fight
this invasion but also now brent it does
open up some other discussions a lot of
analysts have been saying that perhaps
china's militarization needs to be
confronted and that might leave some
space in the agenda over the two-day
summit coming up to discuss other issues
as well